could you use more therapists on The  Bachelor definitely are there any  therapists on there's one yeah you see  them at the beginning and you see them  at the end that's it mm-hmm  well why the beginning in the end well I  mean unless you're really having a  mental breakdown during were you at the  edge I was actually at one point in  Bachelorette I mean both situations it's  a very weird situation and it was much  worse towards the end on the bachelor  much worse do you have the therapist on  the bachelor or just if were contested  uh I shoot probably was there I never  never asked for that I don't think it  would have done any good maybe it would  have I just used whiskey for my therapy  the last two weeks I couldn't sleep so I  wake up at about 3 a.m. and I'd go work  out and then I then I'd have a little  whiskey for breakfast